hello everyone welcome to this
last session of the day
first of all congratulations you are the
highlanders of this set of this
day
you are here you managed to stay
despite the time despite the rain
until today
I am luca politi account manager of
google flight cloud but fortunately
for you it is not me it will not be me
talking will be two pairs of partners and
customers the most fascinating partners and
customers we have so they told me
to introduce them and therefore without wasting any
more time I would introduce the first couple
who are christian wooded by engineer
francesco zovetto di  alstom who will
explain to us how they are simulating and
managing doing a project together
to simulate one of
the largest railway exchanges or rather the largest railway exchange
in europe most complex in europe
tell me now we have to perfect master
thanks luca applause to the most
fascinating of googlers then
good morning everyone I am a Christian
boscat  or ingenuity and very quickly a
minute to tell you everything we have little
time about 100 people we are
basically a
link I will
show you immediately because I want to go
quickly between business and
technology we work on the whole
google trend from the digital marketing
system integrator and  We therefore work
on the technological aspect of big data march
having to computer everything you
have undergone today the sweets up
to the strategy consulting activity
because because it says transformation
means changing the processes you
wrote it say this morning for example from
our customer from barilla  it
also means working on people and therefore
we try to give an enthusiastic offer and
we work with
many high-level customers
including alstom
I have already finished francis we have
little time you all get
along directly thanks Christian phrase thanks
to google for the  I invite alstom a few words
about who we are and what we do other
but  is a French multinational
dealing with the metropolitan railway market
we are practically present in all
sectors of the market for which
we make materializable tram trains
we make signaling systems all
the safety in circulation is
managed by our plates
when you travel on line 1 in milan
when you look on the  speed bologna
florence
rome naples when you turn in the hold of
bologna and many other practices
guarantee the fact that the trains
move without going to cause deaths
are our equipment we do services and
maintenance for the fleets for which for
example 25 years of maintenance for
our  customers who are on TV which are
three in Italy and other bishops and then we have
turnkey plants and then for
example abroad and in riads we raise
plants from structural works in front of a
few numbers about who we are 30,000
employees plus 30,000 employees
around the world we are  in a hundred
non-santina sites in a  tions we have 200
customers london spaces the world 7
billion euros in turnover last year
10 billion orders acquired
last year so to give it a little the
volume of the company clearly
a company of this size due to its
complexity that it has to manage  to stay
close to customers on the one hand to have
a food drink that guarantees
internal standardization and therefore there
are all the regions it
functions as support other than
what helps us in this in Italy to the
press several things are reporting in
particular me
a  I work at the bologna site we take
care of the safety systems
for which on board the train its customers
via high speed in Italy as I have already
said so different technologies and
abroad for example in Denmark
we are remaking half of the network for the
Danish road we are  by redesigning
the traffic management systems throughout
sweden we have acquired a
large project in france in the de
fran  so there are big projects that are
distributed around the world
governed by in this case from bologna
I make a small parenthesis explain
how we came to think about the
cloud
how we think about the cloud he joined the
company
I started working more than twenty
years ago  I worked with c assembler
things that even before three things that
practically if the dinosaurs that
went around the streets related as
the speed of evolution and then the
first times I went to see
they generally talked about cloud
for me it was a dark  such because I
did not understand for france it is okay
webhosting it is okay up but how
did we manage to bring this thing
into operation and technology
we are dealing with manufacturing
with extended plants so it was a
considerable leap and therefore I had vouchers in my hand
and who had started playing with the
voucher to understand how it could be done
on the cloud, a current came
out so I convinced my son to
st  weapons one of his train I opened it he
put us on a board on board to drive
the engine make it go forward and back
another board we put it
somewhere else and slowly he
began to build pieces
around to go up  cloud for which in the
end I had a web server that was on
a linux os machine on the cloud had
another machine that acted as a
gateway sometimes on the cloud on windows and alive
others I left all the
internet firewalls to be able to enter my house
at the end  what I could do was that
from a web page that was up on the
internet I could move the train
back and forth
this actually meant
that the cloud was much more than what
we are used to thinking without
taking anything away from what is done.
billions of euros that goes back
we had what is the possibility of having
machines available
computing power available just in time
possibility of replicating
operating systems that we wanted and therefore  of you have the
opportunity to think
about applications that were to integrate
even in environments that weren't
exactly item and here we come
back to top
we go back to ashton the challenge we
had to face we wanted to
face was to understand how to
go  to face the complexity of
our world with elements of
flexibility that could have died from
applause to our complexity is mainly linked to
two axes one of
technology for the complexity of the
projects think that even if you do not
see railways in the
subways is a quantity  of
electronics that is impressive
information technology everywhere
the fact that they move exchange that
moves safely and linked to
everything six subsystems that talk to each other in
real time guarantee that the
exchange only moves when it has
to move the trips requirement of  customer
that are increasingly stringent
security aspects of sv  the group
that owns us for each project
we put in a row a dedicated development environment
we have times to manage several
stages of evolution and therefore the need
to have an infrastructure that supports us
in all the steps of the
development cycle of a project of this type
on the other hand organizational complexity
we have competing projects but we
have told you about it
we are a multinational that works with
the concert of centers of excellence which
means that from bologna
we make products and apply them
on projects that are in denmark
rather than with the united states  there
are all the skills everywhere
so we have to support our
colleagues through the business world
distributed company extended company not
only our internal company on another
internet but talking to customers with
suppliers therefore a whole series of
problems and we wanted to try
to understand how to do it  to improve the
way we work by working using
the cloud in some unconventional way
the solution we notified
in order to ultimately support the
engineering activities was to use the cloud as
infrastructure as a service
so the way if you want
lower use of resources than
we have on the cloud
we have created a  which is
basically one of the solutions of these
pilots that are based on
things on windows and linux virtual machines
then we create them we configure them with
based on what is needed in terms of
networks in terms of applications in terms
of performance
we have exploited cloud
provisioning  just in time so
we know that this morning we decide
that we want to give the steering from a
project that we need more
resources this afternoon we have 100
machines to 200 machines generated and
available maybe on the other side of the
world to support that project
segregated environments because as we said
we have different
levels of different teams ch  and they work at the
same time and which risk
colliding on the same environment so
we use cloud projects to create
separate environments and access
through the internet that is trivial but
allows us to have visibility across the
whole world and also
share the approach from the customer
to give you an idea, this
solution has allowed us to face, for example,
a situation in which for a single
project for a single
development cycle we needed to process
10,000 hours of calculation of yes thousand
machine hours of a single professor who  it does
all its processing to
get to the bottom of a development cycle
rather than in the past we worked with
a pool of machines to do this type of
internal activity for which we had about
thirty clear servers on the site and not
beautiful TVs but from ours
engineering department we released them
because now each project works with
a hundred machines but we have
arrived  again above said big
active in the 300 in one fell swoop and this
means being able to carry out the
projects managed to work
concurrently accelerate the
development cycles so that before working
with physical albert it was unthinkable
what were the advantages we have
seized by the use of the cloud in
this number one way the fact of being
able to have resources available on the
desk of our designers while
before we had dedicated environments we have
dedicated to do this type of
activity
now we can create
bubble environments on the cloud that are made
available through the  ''
internet access on everyone's desk and
therefore everyone can do their own
simulations proof of concept analysis
speeches in customers
independently
we have already copied the projects we have
decoupled the projects again
we have worked a lot
on cooperation which has 22 aspects on the
one hand  the internal cooperation
here  nto we have configured our
machines to be able to see in real time
by more teams then it may
have people from bologna who work
together with people who are in belgium
person who is milindia watching what
is happening in real time on that
environment and thus unifying  in front of the
application the
communication language because we are all
there and we see exactly what is
happening at that moment we can
discuss it is also a castro factor
in the next t because now we are
able to provide services 9 to the
customer through the same
functionality and  so we are able to
support him instead of physically going
to the site which may be in rome which may
be in genoa which may be
abroad
we have the opportunity to reach them
while they do their business
discuss what is actually
happening and move on for example  on
an analysis where they
stop because they can't av  ere
sufficient elements
and at this point what is after this
this way of using the cloud is
something that started from the
bologna site on a series of pilot projects and
arrived very interesting for which it
was taken as a high
level activity at corporate level and  at this moment
we are defining a governance
to go and identify
the applications to be created and
distributed at the corporate level in all that
the multinational is part of
this aspect, integration with litigation
until yesterday was an
engineering solution that
[Music  ]
was left to exist by the ITI now it
is becoming something that is part
of ours and therefore from
our structure of our
service infrastructure to the business
we do not want to measure and improve the
user experience
up to now are activities that have
been the solutions  been implemented by
engineers for engineers we want to make
this one of the solutions is molt  or
easier to apply so that
anyone around the world can take some
sort of pre-packaged applications and
then build their own solution
for the project they are facing
and finally I like to remember that
the company is clearly integrated in the
territory we have
social responsibility  at the moment we are
starting an integration project of
people who were are different they are
autistic children
I do not say they suffer from disorders because it
is not it is not beautiful it is not even true we are
trying to see how to integrate them
into your business
we have identified  the way
of using the cloud that will
allow us to support the
entire insertion and integration of the
training of these people in environments
that may be more congenial
to them but keeping them strongly linked to
our
activities our way of working
if I can a '  last consideration not
conclusion because we ourselves
are  or walking at this
moment in governance and we are
only beginning to understand what are
the potentialities of using the cloud
for operational technology what we
have seen and that at first at first
experience it was practically a wall
because the world beyond is very particular
of the requirements of  very
stringent security for which the first is married
cannot be used but in reality
starting with quotes playing above
we have found and continue to
see new applications of this type
of technology well thanks to the taxman
[Applause]
thank you very much yes I believe that precisely that
of the  simulation is one of the cases
where the advantages of the cloud are more
evident
instead now we see the opposite case that is
a real migration of
what was the global infrastructure of job
to me then calls on stage filippo
quario rondo 18 mi and piergiorgio del
campo  of clouds to you good morning everyone
I am pier giorgio de field of clouds
and today qu  ello that we want to present
the proposition of clouds the
gaming experience to any company you
represent or a company that is in the
area is a company more oriented towards
manual activities rather than
an innovative company today you will have seen
in all the interventions it needs  to
approach the digital transformation
the new the new digital innovation
for someone will perhaps be more difficult
for someone it will certainly be easier
for fun tunics a company that was
already born in the digital world it was
easier to approach this world so
I leave the word filippo who will
tell us  your experience
hello everyone i'm filippo quario
rondo i am sites or giotto i job tommy
is a website a search engine for
job offers by
connecting to the site you can put the
keyword the location for the job you
prefer where you prefer
I think here  everyone has a job and they
are all happy to know that
they already have tomini however also allows  to
change it naval joking aside played
me a reality that by now you mean for
four years we started in turin
let's say we were born as a start-up
obviously growing from the beginning we
have a party in 22 computer scientists or
gabriele who is currently
the CEO and we
have grown  the company starting
from garage solutions such as how can
two guys be so let's say if a
party in Italy we have put on
an infrastructure the ump for let's say for
the less technical it is
a classic infrastructure with a
linux machine on which  goes to put
a patch that provides the web pages
the php that goes to interpret
what the pages are to render and eg
let's say never sequel which is the database of the
classic par excellence that surfs on
linux
we started for what was
there  'italy enel over the course of 34 years
we have always opened new
countries such growth has led
11 for the last two three years to av  ere
scalability problems let's say at
first the pyre and new countries it
is easy to verticalize
the structure every time by replicating it you arrive at
a certain point where it begins to say but
I have to scale on the single country
so Italy for example for the management for
the  sessions that we managed on the site
so we went from having maybe there is
the 100 views a day of when
we left and then go to a thousand
and then be now with these
days from between 10 and 20 and 30
thousand
here is  needed a radical
transformation of what is the
standard structure that
we had tried so when with
the opening of the thirty-fourth country
of horizontals give what is the
structure then the whole structure that
was vertical bring it horizontally
and between the solutions  we looked for
we found the friends of clouds who
absolutely suggested us to
try google cloud
we did some experiments
at the beginning that immediately led us to
see the potential behind
all the infrastructure and the platform
the services they offer let's say in a
month we went from having 8
super-loaded servers with I don't know how many gb of
ram
not  I know how many and how many cpus a well-known
Italian provider has a
replicated structure divided into three clusters for
continent Asia America Europe which
therefore allowed us to have these three
clusters with web database service and a
load balancer directly managed by
google therefore also as
systems management we have no
particular places for what concerns
all system engineers and managed
directly by google and this we say
a very great value that brings for
everything that concerns the
management
we say that the migration of 34 countries
we were able to do in a  month and I
think part of the credit also goes to the
fact that the deployment speed on
google platforms is unmatched and
impresses  nte to see that one enters
the console
ab a machine thirty seconds later it is
already the basic operating machine
or with some
software features already pre-installed
let's say this allowed us to be
fast on the development and
migration of 18 gives me a
purely physical structure  virtual dynamic structure
on the cloud
let's say that the migration has led to an
increase of about 10 from 10 to 30
percent of the response speed
of our web pages
, particularly in non-European
wholesale countries before 18 mica are
centralized pre-cloud structure on what
was then  was Italy the latency times
the other side of the ocean were
dangerous for what was the user
experience of the user. this in fact
penalized us in the past and we were
able to fill this user experience gap
so let's say from a  from a technological point of view
we have achieved this
result which is very satisfactory
which was then reflected i  n an increase in
performance regarding
what the product is
our corporate mission and making
people find work is a
10 percent increase in
speed reflected on 10
percent more clicks on the site 11
percent of  more application and therefore
in the end we assume that in Italy
the job market that the people we
help through work find
work 10 percent more frequently
thanks to this step awards dowd
we also say that emigrating to google
cloud means not going to keep a
maintain and manage the system yes ok it's
okay to set it up it's okay but then
also be free from
the burdens of having to maintain it day
by day all tolerance is
managed directly by google and this of
course brings further speed and
the ability to focus on
also produced then being of Genoese origins
I see very fascinating the fact of being
able to turn off the machines  ine therefore also
save some money maybe at
night or during the holidays and there are fewer
people looking for work also because
rightly at night one sleeps is fine
so let's say this too is an
added value on which we have always
managed to adopt as a lever
I would like to conclude  saying that then to
conclude as he said to his friend before
he is not not the master I would like to observe
that concentrating on the product and no longer
on the structure really allows
you to focus
on what are
the characteristics of the product as the
characteristics also mean the
analysis processing  data and with google
we have been taking
the first steps for a few months now on what
are the technologies for managing
data manipulation and soon we will probably
implement google machine
learning on the cloud again for
data management and
then extrapolation  of partners and going to let's say
always improve the custo user experience
mized user by user
I would like to make an analogy for a moment
since we moved to the cloud
before we weren't on the cloud obviously
but there is an analogy about riding a
bike last Saturday I went
cycling with my father  and let's say my
father at 65 is no longer lively but
I still like to explore moving around
I went with my cross country mountain bike
and my father had to
rent a robot of the Madonna it will not
be a fantastic bike and it was an
electric one and let's go outside  'eagle that in the
valle d'aosta basha van
I don't know how many kilometers we have done
reminds me of the end and roero dead but
we arrive like almost to the top
I look at the clock what is it made of
late you go that is the electric bike you go
much faster  I can't keep up with you
what he did he went to his
came back down he gave me the
electric bike I went up here in the
moment when I used the
electric bike I thought about but I would
still have arrived s  upera with the
electric bike it took me nothing to get
to google cloud a bit so in the sense
many of you maybe are in start up they
have been in start up and keep the start
up and those who believe in it and push at
will and the fact  then to say, however,
having an extra tool that
allows you to get before it
benefits in what the world of the
telephone has me especially in the
business of what a web company
here I wanted to conclude now filippo
philippe's experience was very
interesting  it is
their business the value of the company is
very interesting and let's say that it has
been able to take advantage of what is
the world of google to
further improve their solution
not all companies, however, start from
this solution
some very fast data this the
red arrow indicated the Italian GDP and
the blue arrow indicates and
digital investments perhaps all companies
in Italy have decided that after the crisis to
invest in  l digital and therefore something
can also be seen within the dl
of the trend of the nation
that improves investing in digital
also means perhaps not
everyone knows how to access
very important tax reliefs so even at the
right time because if I invest  and
optimize my structure my organization
I can recover investments and
therefore what is the way to move towards
the cloud
today we are talking above all about
infrastructure services in general
certainly companies like Filippo
's do it naturally they
are the first maybe it goes to  use
this
solution others can do it in a new way
which is the hybrid way of hybrid
infrastructure adoption gartner predicts
that in the next few years there will be
huge investments within
this system it is because we
all know that the scalable cloud
that once  I adopt the cloud,
Filippo said I can specialize in my
business and not  machine management
so on
what we add perhaps that not
everyone can take their data and
throw them on the cloud therefore
hybrid situations also meet
internal resistance to
fundamental architectural solutions
necessary for their
company and the cloud proposal  is
to accompany companies that need to
adopt who want to adopt the cloud
in three different
steps starting from the infrastructure google
provides the cloud is a
series of tools that can go to
define areas fundamentally
dedicated to their company so
ruby is clear xpm  adopting klein the
carrier cloud means making a
very simple self-made question my
company has sufficient connectivity
to manage remote servers I will have to
upgrade it and so on
so once I have made the sense I will have to
do the design the implementation of
lin trains and not only will I have to
probably fit again  the tools
something I will already find in google
something else I will have to adopt it in order to
manage all this solution
once the cloud is open I access
many of all the services that google
makes available
at this point the first user of these
services and arguments himself imagine the
backup simply once I have
a secure area in my company I can
get rid of backup many companies that
offer backup systems are already
partners of google and so I can
lighten all my solutions
finally what I can do I can
go and manage
applications  it is perhaps the third level
filippo in perhaps the case of q bernes he
took his applications issued on the
new infrastructure and you run it
already someone went maybe he has to
modify them someone has to rewrite them
again and so he can ride the
third honda of the cloud where  I don't
use and technologies and filippo has
introduced that were from some time ago
but I review  the new architectures where
I rely heavily not only on
infrastructure if service but also
on platform and service, i.e. services
managed in this case by google,
particularly interesting such as
pious vision and the
machine, big data and so on that easily
allow me to redo the  my application
in a new and interesting way
google does this as a partner
accompanying the customer then
listening to choosing choosing
technologies integrate them accelerate by
guiding what is the solution
we are quite attached to this
slide people processes data
technology technology we put it in the end
always goes  in the end because projects of
this type are technological projects
but if seen within a company they
are above all projects that impact
people on the people of the ITI
rather than the people who managed
the applications so you need to have a
strong control of the part of  changes
impact on processes changes to  company
does not change only the server that from
physical becomes virtual and then the data
and technologies arrive at the
end
I too have finished almost precise time
and therefore we are
[Applause]
very well thank you very much we have therefore
heard two very different cases
is  however extremely interesting I think
one of lists in shift or as we
like to call it we move and nimrud therefore
not only move but also improve
during this phase of change and
the other of high performance computing simulation
the two very interesting cases two of the
best Italian partners  with whom we
collaborate a lot, I have
nothing but thanks